science is about trying to get rigorous
answers to questions about how nature
works and it's a very important process
that's actually quite reliable if
carried out correctly with generation of
hypotheses and testing of those by
accumulation of data and then drawing
conclusions that are continually
revisited to be sure they're right so if
you want to answer questions about how
nature works how biology works for
instance science is the way to get there
scientists believe in that and they are
very troubled by a suggestion that other
kinds of approaches can be taken to
derive truth about nature and some I
think have seen faith as therefore a
threat to the scientific method and
therefore to be resisted but faith in
its proper perspective is really asking
a different set of questions and that's
why I don't think there needs to be a
conflict here the kinds of questions
that faith can help one address or more
in the philosophical realm why are we
all here why is there something instead
of nothing is there a god isn't it clear
that those aren't scientific questions
and that science doesn't have much to
say about them but you either have to
say well those are inappropriate
questions and we can't discuss them or
you have to say we need something
besides science to pursue some of the
things that humans are curious about for
me that makes perfect sense but I think
for many scientists particularly for
those who have seen the shrill
pronouncements from extreme views that
threaten that what they're doing
scientifically and feel therefore that
they they can't really include those
thoughts into their own worldview faith
can be seen as as an enemy and similarly
on the other side some of my scientific
colleagues who are of an atheist
persuasion are sometimes using science
as a club over the head of believers
basically suggesting that anything that
can't be reduced to a scientific
question isn't important and it just
represents superstition it should be
gotten rid of part of the problem is I
think the the extremists have occupied
the stay
those voices are the ones we hear I
think most people are actually kind of
comfortable with the idea that science
is a reliable way to learn about nature
but it's not the whole story and there's
a place also for religion for faith for
theology for philosophy but that harmony
perspective doesn't get as much
attention nobody's as interested in
harmony as they are in conflict I'm
afraid
my study of genetics certainly tells me
in controvert ibly that Darwin was right
about the nature of how living things
have arrived on the scene by descent
from a common ancestor under the
influence of natural selection over very
long periods of time
Darwin was amazingly insightful given
how limited the molecular information he
had was essentially it didn't exist now
with the digital code of DNA we had the
best possible proof of darwin's theory
that he could have imagined so that
certainly tells me something about the
nature of living things but it actually
adds to my sense that this is a answer
to a how question and it leaves the why
question still hanging in the air
other aspects of our universe I think
also for me as for Einstein raise
questions about the possibility of an
intelligence behind all of this
why is it for instance that the
constants that determine the behavior of
matter and energy like the gravitational
constant for instance have precisely the
value that they have to in order for
there to be any complexity at all in the
universe that is fairly breathtaking in
its lack of probability of ever having
happened and it does make you think that
a mind might have been involved in
setting the stage at the same time that
does not imply necessarily that that
mind is controlling the specific
manipulations of things that are going
on in the natural world in fact I would
very much resist that idea I think the
laws of nature potentially could be the
product of a mind I think that's a
defensible perspective but once those
laws are in place then I think nature
goes on and science has the chance to be
able to perceive how that works and what
its consequences are